Hi, I'm Alex Nicksay, a
senior engineer at Google.
I lead the front
ends team at YouTube.
Over 6 billion hours of
video are watched each month
on YouTube.
That's almost an hour for
every person on earth.
At YouTube, we want to
get that video to you
as fast as possible.
Since last year,
we've reduced the time
to start video playback
by over a second.
That's 40% faster.
So where did we start
in this optimization?
We analyzed data from
our real user monitoring,
and we broke down
the time it takes
to start playback
into critical stages.
And we realized that
one of those stages
is the same for every playback--
initializing the player.
So we asked ourselves, what
if we reuse the same player?
The answer?
It's faster.
By maintaining a
persistent player,
we're doing less work
on each navigation.
And by doing less work, we're
making each playback start
sooner.
So how did we do it?
We built a new JavaScript
framework for page navigation.
Structured page fragments,
or SPF for short,
is a lightweight framework that
handles navigations and updates
to page sections.
When someone first
arrives at the site,
the content is sent from the
server and rendered normally.
We call this static navigation.
But when going to the next
page, only document fragments
are sent and page sections
are updated accordingly.
We call this dynamic navigation.
So what does this give us?
It gives us the fastest
possible rendering time
for that first page, leveraging
all of our existing performance
techniques.
And it additionally
allows us to maintain
a persistent responsive
interface using
the same rendering
code as before.
This all creates a
better user experience.
No one is staring at a blank
white screen waiting for a page
to load.
But what about the
developer experience?
This framework allows us
to maintain productivity
by using the same code for both
static and dynamic rendering.
And it gives us the flexibility
to use any server side language
and template system we want.
It also supports
sending data for use
in client side templating.
So let's take a look at
how it's implemented.
We'll start with
requesting content.
Here's a link.
Clicking it will trigger a
static navigation request.
Here's that same link using SPF.
Clicking it will trigger a
dynamic navigation request.
As you can see, we use
progressive enhancement
and a simple syntax to enable
SPF for supported browsers.
Now let's look at sending
that content back.
Here's the HTML of a response
for static navigation.
In this example, we
use a common layout
of upper masthead, middle
content, and lower footer.
Here's that same
response using SPF.
Only the fragment for
the middle content
is sent because the
masthead and the footer
don't need to change.
JSON is used for transport
during dynamic navigation.
As you can see, the fragments
for static navigation
map directly to those
for dynamic navigation.
And this makes the
implementation very easy.
Now we won't cover
them in depth,
But SPF has several
optional features
that can help you
improve your site.
In some web apps, HTTP
caching is inappropriate,
but SPF allows you to cache
responses in client memory
according to your application
specific parameters.
SPF can also prefetch responses
automatically or manually
to predictively
boost performance.
And SPF supports streaming
multipart responses in chunks
to enable on the fly processing.
This speeds up navigation by
starting the rendering early.
Now let's take a brief look
at when YouTube launched
these features, and how they
each impacted performance.
Here's real data from
YouTube's real user monitoring.
I've graphed the median
time to start playback
for both HTML5,
Flash, and the traffic
weighted composite of both.
But for clarity,
we're going to focus
on the five day moving
average of the composite.
Now when we first introduced
dynamic navigation
between consecutive
video pages, we
didn't have a
persistent player yet.
And we only saw a minor
reduction in overall time
to playback.
Despite this, users reported
that the site felt faster.
This showed us that there were
some very real user perceived
performance gains that
dynamic navigation brings.
Now when we added
that persistent player
between consecutive
video pages in Chrome,
we reduced the overall time
until playback by 8 and 1/2%.
Expanding all supported browsers
was another 9% improvement.
And enabling on the fly
processing over HTTP chunking
yielded a 5% speed up.
By defaulting supported
browsers to our HTML5 player,
we reduced our overall
player initialization time
and generated an 8% improvement.
And then by
dynamically navigating
between all pages on
the site, not just
consecutive video pages, we
were able to preemptively create
a persistent player
before it was even used.
And this reduced our
overall time until playback
by 7 and 1/2%.
When we expanded our default
HTML player to both videos
with and without ads, we
yielded a 2% improvement.
And finally, enabling on
the fly processing over SPDY
yielded a 4 and 1/2% speed up.
And that's how we
made it 40% faster
to play a video on YouTube.
So what's next?
The great news is that we've
open source the framework so
you can use SPF on your site.
Check out our project page
on GitHub to learn more.
Thanks for watching.